this is Tamura sane standing in for
reviewer Steve Watts trousers of mana is
not a bold reinvention while it has been
given a graphical overhaul and added
systems that help flesh out and
modernize the combat systems this remake
of a once obscure RPG is very much
rooted in its own history and by some
combination of that history and the
modern enhancements it has a bundle of
great ideas that are often hampered by
others that are obtuse or confusing
from the start trials of mana
distinguishes itself from other
traditional Japanese RPGs by presenting
a pool of heroes the first thing you do
is select three of the six characters to
be your party and that decision will
loss throughout the game you can swap
between any of these characters in the
heat of battle while the other two will
manage on their own with some simple
preset behaviors but your primary
character is treated as the game's
protagonist during major story moments
it's an inventive idea that adds a layer
of personalization and a criss-crossing
narrative the stakes of the overall
story remained the same but by
presenting you with a selection of six
different prologues you get to see the
various motivations that led your
custom-built party to be thrown into
this grand adventure you have my
blessing on your journey thank you your
majesty the other characters that you
left unchosen appear in brief cameos and
it's implied that their own quest is
still happening just off-camera as they
go it alone
however this quality cuts both ways cars
of mana has you choose the three who
will last you for the entire adventure
before you know anything about them or
how the game will proceed while all team
compositions are probably viable some
are more sensible than others so it's
entirely possible to get knee deep
before wishing you'd made different
choices I had chosen Risa as my main
character with the promise that she's a
strong range fighter with the brawler
Kevin and he lishala as my backup I
imagine hanging back and doing range
damage while Kevin pulled a grow several
hours in I realized that her ranged
abilities are fairly limited and as I
was flying up close anyway I might as
well be controlling Kevin instead since
his aggressive fighting style and
powerful attacks were much more
satisfying
I also regretted choosing Charlotte
albeit for completely different reasons
much of the English voice acting in
trials of mana is hokey and still it but
fine and functional enough
Charlotte's is obnoxious in large part
because the localization accents her
youthfulness with a heavy speech
impediment if it was meant to be
endearing it failed I had reservations
the moment my characters May up with her
but by then I didn't want to turn back
and repeat the beginning of the game
plus Sharla is also the only dedicated
healer so just about any given team
composition
would likely need to include her whether
you like it or not the characters
themselves are familiar fantasy tropes
but strangely many of them share almost
identical qualities - all three of my
characters were heirs to a noble family
two of them an actual prince and
princess chased out of their kingdom by
family strife or tragedy there's nothing
necessarily wrong with leaning on these
archetypes for a fantasy story but it
feels formulaic when seeing them
back-to-back in three different
prologues most of the time in trials of
mana is spent in combat interspersed
with simple pathfinding an occasional
platforming the combat is surprisingly
fluid especially in the late game when
you've unlocked a wide array of moves
and combos the mana series is known for
being action focused and this remake
lovingly captures that quality in its
transition from 2d to 3d combat feels
weighty
and the powerful klaustreich abilities
grant the appropriate feeling of
overwhelming your opponent's upgrading
your character eventually leads to
bigger combo chains giving you more
versatility in the heat of battle by the
end it feels so naturally like a
character action game that it's RPG
roots are just running under the hood as
enjoyable as the combat is though some
of the elements surrounding the battle
system can be confusing or obtuse you
start earning elemental spirits which
grant magical abilities long before you
could reasonably have leveled up enough
to gain access to those abilities huh
tooltips kept telling me I could equip
these spells in the training menu
implying they were immediately available
and I spent too much time hunting for
abilities that didn't yet exist the
third tier class upgrades which are
already gated behind a level requirement
are also gated behind special seeds and
the game isn't immediately clear about
where to look for them and once you find
those seeds the classes they grow on are
randomized between a handful of sets so
you may not get the variant you wanted
curses
this the story meanders oddly with the
nemesis introduced in various prologues
coming and going without much rhyme or
reason the plot runs out of steam about
halfway through the main quest and since
the second half of the game is nonlinear
the story pieces don't really relate to
one another
it's instead a series of vignettes
leading up to the reveal of the big bad
and a final confrontation those staid
elements are unfortunate because the
world of the mana series is filled with
joyful moments of whimsy and weirdness
this is a game in which you travel
between villages by being shot out of a
cannon built by a gnome named bon voyage
once you need to take to the sea your
method of conveyance becomes a giant
tail or wearing a snorkeling gear
enemies have names like assistant and
captain duck it's just delightfully
oddball and helps soften some of the
more dire melodrama Charles of - stands
on the strength of its combat and the
fact that it's how you spend the vast
majority of your time that easy
recommendation comes qualified with
several elements that don't work nearly
as well from dull and hodgepodge
storytelling to bewildering progression
systems seeing a historical curiosity
through the lens of a mostly modernized
action RPG was enough to pull me through
the experience despite my cripples
though so there's certainly still life
in the world of mana
[Music]
you
[Music]